يوم [الموسيقى] الأجنبية
عندما تم إطلاعي على البالون ،
أمرت البنتاغون بإسقاطه يوم
الأربعاء في أقرب وقت ممكن ،
قرروا دون إلحاق الضرر بأي شخص
على الأرض ،
نعم ، ستطلب الصين إعادته
واستجابتنا  ربما
لا ، لم نكن نعيدهم إليهم ،
لكن هذه ستكون
عملية طويلة الأمد كما تعلمون ، كما هو الحال في البداية ،
سنجمعها ونجري
الطب الشرعي عليها
إذا كان قرار الصين بالتحليق هو
منطاد للمراقبة فوق
القارة.  الولايات المتحدة
غير مقبولة وغير مسؤولة على حد سواء وهذا ما يدور
حوله هذا
انتهاك لسيادتنا إنه
انتهاك للقانون الدولي
لذلك أعتقد من
منظور عام ووجهة
نظر الرأي العام يضر بشكل كبير
بعلاقة الولايات المتحدة مع الصين لأنه
أظهر مدى  برنامج التجسس الصيني
وما هم على استعداد للقيام به
لجمع المعلومات الاستخبارية من الولايات المتحدة